what's up guys welcome to our e3 sets
here's Amanda you look so pretty this is
awesome so we are gonna be live for what
was 17 hours
17 17 you guys can watch on Spike TV and
you can watch all access dot spike calm
for pretty much absolutely everything
we're literally gonna be live for the
next two days like non-stop like this
copy I'm going to be something yeah so
many go let me show you guys this right
here this is our GT III social media
board are you ready
so basically we're gonna be populating
tweets and Facebook posts all right here
and I'm gonna be reading them live on
air so make sure you guys tweet us make
sure you use the hashtag GT e3 you can
follow me on twitter follow Spike TV
follow at game trailers goodies so if
you're not a fan of e3 we're gonna be
starting here really really shortly
right off side everything is starting to
to get underway
yeah I'm sure you're set this is my
station this is our lounge this is where
Amanda and Jeff teleprompter so great
but yeah weird me starting here soon but
I some to let you guys know so stay
tuned next few days leave me a comment
below and let me know what you're most
looking forward to
at e3 okay bye oh wait hey Jeff what was
i the Internet
hello Internet are we live on yeah so
you're ready for this
I am ready Justine it's gonna be
exciting it's a full day of gaming
goodness
and we'll black ops 2 I saw you tweeting
about that this morning I did i
retweeted you I was really excited world
premiere demo of black ops 2 is coming
up live on our stage and you've got the
coolest thing I got ourselves like
just like mega iPads yeah it's awesome
it's gonna be cool so we'll be doing
that live all day yep on the net at some
all-access spike calm yeah we'll see you
guys live half hour
tweet us okay guys